[Music]
democrats can't get their act together
when it comes to biden's radical
spending bill they're at odds with the
numbers the pet pop projects and now
they're arguing over the inclusion of
the hyde amendment this provision bans
federal funding for elective abortions
and democrats senator joe manchin wants
it included in the bill but far left
members of his own party want it gone
for good joining me now to react fox and
friends weekend co-host rachel campos
duffy and liz wheeler host of the liz
wheeler show
liz the hyde amendment used to be
something that was just a an agreed upon
thing had bipartisan support it was
included whenever you were sending these
things out and democrats would run on
saying you know well i'm personally you
know have certain views on abortion but
i don't think we should use your money
to fund it what changed
well the radical left aoc the squad um
came in and changed
changed the democratic party as you know
i mean the height amendment as you
mentioned the height amendment used to
be a nonpartisan bipartisan thing when
it was introduced by um henry hyde i
think there were a hundred democrats who
supported it at that time and and listen
this this is something that represents
the majority of the country the hyde
amendment has estimated to have saved
two and a half million unborn children
um from abortion those precious babies
have been saved this is this is not
something that is a democratic issue
versus a republican issue when you ask
the voters it's only that partisan in
washington dc there's a new poll that
says that 58
of the american people do not want
taxpayer money used to pay for abortions
um only 38 percent of americans want
that that's a huge divide ben a huge
divide and that divide actually
accurately accurately reflects um the
popular opinion on abortion itself the
vast majority of the american people
want restrictions on abortion eighty
percent of people both pro-abortion and
pro-life think abortion should be
illegal in the third trimester sixty
percent of people think abortion should
be illegal in the second trimester
because abortion is a brutal gruesome
procedure that not only ends the life of
an unborn child but harms women too the
democrats are ignoring their
constituents in in the interest of their
own political agenda
you know in rachel you are uh familiar
of course i'm sure with many pro-life
democrats from union households catholic
households across the country
who nonetheless have voted for democrats
over the years and yet they've they've
done so during this great cultural sort
where all of the pro-life democrats that
we used to be familiar with have been
pushed out of the party that they they
don't have a place to go anymore
it's it's astounding the numbers that
liz quoted are accurate how much that
doesn't represent their own constituency
yeah i mean the the biden administration
is the most radical pro-abortion
administration in u.s history and they
are totally out of step joe manchin is
actually doing a favor to the party by
trying to bring them a little bit in
step
but our country is divided and our
country is divided on this
moral issue for the same reason
our country was divided over slavery any
time that you have people who are
powerful
who want to profit out of deciding who
is sufficiently human enough to live um
you know you can do anything you want to
somebody once you decide they're not
sufficiently human we had this uh
cultural um debate in the 1800s we're
having it now and thanks to technology
as senator blackburn talked about um the
the the pro-abortion side is losing
because millions of women and and
frankly their children um their their
their children who are alive are meeting
their siblings in utero um because those
images are so clear they're so profound
they cannot be argued with and um the
radical abortionists on the other side
the pro-abortionists they they look so
delusional they look so antiquated as
they cling to these you know 1970
notions of fetal development i mean you
just cannot i can tell you ben the
ultrasound that i saw with my oldest
evita down to the ultrasound i saw with
my youngest who is two years old it's
just night and day i mean i could see
musculature i could see you know
fingernails so clearly her little cheeks
look exactly the same now as they did in
utero with my last baby technology is on
our side and um we're winning this
debate not for religious reasons as you
know ben our country is not becoming
more religious it's becoming more
secular but technology is actually
bolstering um this this argument um for
four pro-lifers and we're winning on
that liz real quick uh you have seen
this happen within your own generation
you've seen the shifts that have
happened there despite the dominant
heights of of hollywood and their like
being owned by the pro-abortion side why
do you think that resistance has
happened
yeah i think rachel's absolutely correct
i mean we're the refrigerator door
generation right we grew up seeing the
ultrasound pictures of our brothers and
sisters on the refrigerator door i mean
i know how i felt at six weeks when i
was six weeks pregnant with my daughter
hearing that heartbeat i mean it's
life-changing you know that that's a
human being inside but i think it's also
because we've started talking about the
reality of what abortion is what the
procedure actually does whether it's a
first trimester abortion that poisons a
baby whether it's a second or third
trimester abortion that rips the baby
apart limb from limb poisons a lethal
injection to the heart to stop that
baby's heartbeat when people realize the
gruesome reality of what abortion is
they can't help but
recognize that it's an atrocity to be
committing against fellow human beings
even if they're in the womb
liz and rachel thank you so much for
taking the time to join me this evening